du jour on va revenir sur une histoire
complètement dingue c'était il y a 30
ans quasiment jour pour jour Patrick
Tissier surnommé l'ogre de perpignon
vous en avez tous entendu parler un
homme de 41 ans été condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité pour
avoir menoté Bayonnais cagoulé violé tué
par étranglement puis violer à nouveau
une fillette de 8 ans
Karine ce soir son frère Frédéric vient
témoigner sur notre plateau pourquoi car
depuis le 21 septembre le bourreau de sa
sœur pour être libéré malgré la
perpétuité de sa sa condamnation plus
c'est un
multirécidiviste ça choque forcément
beaucoup de monde regardez ce qui a été
dit sur les JIT le soir du 21 septembre
93 lorsque les enquêteurs investissent
cette bastide ils savent qu'il n'y a
plus lieu d'espérer au fond d'un puit le
corps de la petite Karine Volker 8 ans
disparu depuis 9 jours son meurtrier
tout juste interpellé et passé aux aveux
tisier expliquera son geste par une
pulsion une envie subite de violer après
1 heure et demi de délibér
les jurés se prononcent pour la peine
maximale la réclusion criminelle à
perpété a sortie d'une période de sûeté
de 30 ans Patrick tisser a passé 30 ans
derrière les barreaux il est désormais
en droit de demander sa liberté
conditionnelle à 71 ans voilà vous
l'avez bien entendu il est désormais en
droit de demander sa liberté
conditionnelle à 71 ans et c'est ça qui
fait peur à à Frédéric qui est avec nous
Frédéric donc qui est le frère de Karine
vous aviez 20 ans à peu près quand DRAM
est survenu Frédéric on a l'impression
que 20 ans après euh on dirait que ça
s'est passé hier pour vous 30 ans après
d' 30 ans après on a l'impression que
c'est c'était c'était hier mais c'est
gravé et puis c'était c'est gravé dans
touteçon c'est'est gravé à fire blanc
dans dans les mémoires et oui rien qu'à
savoir qui peut qui peut sortir
ça ça bouleverse la famille mais non
énormément ma mère et puis
nous-même c'est
que
ça ça fait ça fait mal avec à savoir qu'
peut qui pourrait qui pourrait parce que
qu'est-ce qui vous fait peur dans enfin
qu'est-ce qui vous boulverse dans sa
sortie c'est c'est c'est parce que vous
avez peur qu' se qu'il fasse bien sûr
encore des méfé ou bien c'est le
traumatisme de savoir qu'il est dehors
alors que votre sœur de 8 ans a
vécu voilà c'est bah c'est c'est c'est
horrible
passé la peur qui revient finir
qu'est-ce qui a commencé et puis ben
surtout pour la pour les gens pour
prévenir les gens que au fait si on
viendrait à lâcher cet homme dans la
nature enfin pour moi c'est pas un homme
c'est une bête ouais et c'est ouvrir la
cage à un prédateur et que ce prédateur
pourrait se retrouver à habiter à côté
de votre sœur votre frère votre votre
tante c'est important ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui Frédéric c'est que vous
venez aussi témoigner parce que il il a
peur voilà que cette personne ressort et
il pense à tous les gens qui savent pas
qui est ce cet ogre de perpignon
d'ailleurs pourquoi on le surnommait
l'ogre de perpignon bah c'est la
barbarite ce qu'il a fait à la petite
c'est terrible hein il a mais c'est un
multirécidiviste multirécidiviste c'est
ça c'est dès qu'il sort voilà toute sa
vie en tout il a passé 48 ans en prison
48 ans et dès qu'il sort il commets un
crime ou un viol voilà c'est son c'est
son principe pour satisfaire ses besoins
sexuels il a besoin de torturer donc du
coup le risque encore aujourd'hui
au-delà de de du drame que vous vivez le
risque c'est qu'il recommence tout
simplement puis qu'il n'a fait que ça
mais comment on peut relaisser sortir un
gars comme ça c'est ça qui est fou non
mais n'importe quoi comment vous pouvez
avoir même les excusez-moi le cran de
demander une remise de peine encore pour
un gars comme ça non mais excusez-moi
chaque soir on le dit on devient ici on
marche vraiment sur la tête le terme
perpétuité ça veut dire quoi du coup per
aujourd'hui à cause des droits européens
ça s'arrête à 30 ans et à partir de 30
ans la perpétuité elle est un petit peu
remise en question et c'est pour ça que
ça problème c'est aujourd'hui ça fait 30
ans et il peut demander une remise de
peine alors que il a été théoriquement à
perpété Daniel tu voulais dire quelque
chose oui parce que je voudrais quand
même qu'on qu'on comprenne ce que c'est
que la justice c'est-à-dire que cette
personne à 12 ans il a essayé de violer
sa sœur à 16 ans il a essayé de violer
sa belle-mère il l'a il a essayé de
l'étrangler et il l'a frappé à la tête
ensuite à 20 ans il a eu une petite amie
elle s'est refusé à lui il l'a tué il a
été en prison il a une permission pour
bonne conduite il a il a violé deux
personnes pendant deux filles pendant
cette cette et ensuite il a eu 10 ans de
prison et là quand il a été libéré pour
faire ce qu'on sait sur Karine il était
libéré pour bonne conduite donc ça voilà
ce que c'est que la justice en France
excusez-moi j'ai résumé quelque chose
quand même assz Hucin et c'est cette
personne qu'on va peut-être croiser un
jour si c'est à nouveau s'il est à
nouveau libéré c'est cette personne
qu'on aura peut-être comme voisin après
voilà après après la justice ils ont se
calme un peu on n pas dit qu'il était
dehors non mais la justice là ils ont
demandé le tribunal d'application des PE
ça s'appelle le TAP ça s'appelle le TAP
le tribunal d'application des peines
contrairement au [__] un seul juge là ce
seront trois juges qui décideront si oui
ou non ils accordent cette
demande je pense que à 100 % cette
demande ne ser fréri vous êtes inqu vous
croyez que ça peut
aboutir
comme la justice française on ne sait
pas mais bon bah justice elle a quand
même Reis de la perpétuité contre lui
donc ou perpétuité c'est que elle ma
sœur elle l' elle l'a perpuité elle
c'est ave que lui il va sortir il pourra
en profiter mais que nous il nous a
gâché les moments avec notre sœur elle
elle a pas pu profiter d'avoir une une
famille nous on n' pas pu profiter
d'avoir les petits les enfants de de ma
sœur ma sœur n'a pas pu voir pour les
les jooueurs mais ce qui fait peur c'est
que il risque de rebousiller une notre
famille en faisant ce qu' a fait à
toutes ces personnes
oui ça ça fait peur
mais non si on viendrait à le laisser
sortir c'est la personne qui laisse
sortir c'est eux qui devrait être
responsable c'est eux que on devrait les
tenir coupable parce que c'est leur sera
leur responsabilité combien de fois il
est s il est en il é en prison il est
ressorti combien de fois euh plus de
5 si au moins puisque 48 ans de prison
là il a eu 30 ans il y avait eu d'autres
condamnations plein de fois et depuis
tout petit il a été condamné depuis très
jeune il n'a fait que ça et puis il dit
lui-même cyil il y a une lettre à sa
mère où il dit il dit lui-même je je
prendrai 30 ans et je ressortirai et
dans quel état comme s'il menaçait
potentiellement moi ce que je trouve
déjà invraisemblable c'est qu'il ose
demander c'est qu'il ose demander à il
dit je m'en fiche il dit je m'en fiche
je sais que
ors
dans C'est pas leses sont responsa il
faut arrêter parce que on tape beaucoup
sur les
juges lesesuvent pas revenir sur code
pénal parce que parfis les maises
respect
et donc il y a une automaticité un
moment à partir du duquel tu peux
demander la remise en liberté mais comme
le disaits justement Valé le tribunal va
se réunir ils peuvent très bien estimer
par exemple qu'il n'est pas soigné et
que il est pas en capacité de sortir en
tous les cas j'espère là pour le coup il
y aura une décision et
bonpp il veut pas de toute façon que
comme il a il a dit il veut pas se faire
soigner parce que pour lui c'est pas lui
le problème c'est la société le problème
toujours comme
ça qui et en plus c'est que le le pour
lui les les gens qui assassinent pour
lui c'est qu'un tas dos de chair déjà
qu' on dit ça on n'est pas
normal voilà c'est pas ça ça fait peur
en are famille parce
que ce qui pour s'attaquer à ma famille
de vengeance ou
voilà sortira peut-être pas mais on la
vie on ne sait pas comment je pas
à reprendre une vie normale fréri vous
et votre famille derrière alors moi je
je suis protégé on va dire de je me suis
je me suis un peu caché j'ai un peu
laissé un peu tomber ma mère com comme
je dis elle me dit que non et puis là
mes enfants maintenant qui sont grands
j'ai pu aller protéger entre guillemets
c'est que maintenant je veux faire parce
que ma mère est très fatigué de tout ça
mon frère aussi ils sont ils sont pas
bien bien sûr c'est normal moi aussi
mais là ça fait 30 ans que je me suis tu
on va dire et que il faut faire en sorte
que ces personnes qui font des choses
horribles comme
ça faut trouver une peine maintenant il
y a la peine tiser qui les gens qui font
ça ils prennent 30 ans mais tiser lui il
a pris que 10 ans pour ma sœur il a pris
que 10 ans et que ma sœur elle est dans
un trou elle sortira plus jamais
elle sortira plus jamais que lui il peut
peut-être mais normalement il devrait
pas sortir comme on nous dit mais on a
la peur on a la peur on a la peur qui
qui qui qui sort et s'il viendrait à
sortir j'ai peur de moi bousiller ma
famille pour faire pour pour faire des
bêtises que je ne pourrais que voilà je
pas à me rabaisser à son niveau mais
c'est que vous avez vous acculumé même
dans toute la famille on a une on a une
haine dans la famille mon mon frère pe
vous avez peur vous avez peur d'un jour
qui rorte et le
croiser ça mettez-vous à ma place bien
sûrou mettez-vous à ma place vous ferez
quoi si vous croiserez la personne qui a
qui a fait du mal à à un de vos enfants
mais c'est sûr que voilà c'est tout
c'est si sort c'est moi c'est juste
prévenir les gens s'il sort c'est que
vous allez vous allez l'avoir comme
voisin comme ami parce qu'il sait bien
faire mais moi ce que je veux c'est
qu'on qu'on le quand s'il viendrait mais
bon j'espère qu'il restera encore 10 ans
mais comment le savoir comment le savoir
qu'il va rester enfermé que plus il est
enfermé plus nous c'est une sécurité
plus on a moins d'inquiétude et moi
c'est surtout c'est pas pour me protéger
moi je m'en fous c'est c'est surtout
protéger les autres personnes comme dans
le public il y a peut-être dans le
public il va peut-être se retrouver à
côté de votre voisin votre frère votre
sœur et puis ben al il arrivera le drame
et on dira on aurait pas dû le laisser
sortir
encore
mais disons pour ma sœur qu'est-ce qu' a
fait à
cette à cette petite fille de 8 ans
c'est c'est inhumain bien sûr
oui il faut dire que c'est suite à cette
affaire que la justice a évolué puisque
pierre MGU à l'époque a fait voter une
loi qui a permis justement de passer à
la perpétuité réelle avec les 30 ans
incomprensibles c'est après cette
affaire là on pe même on peut même pas
le rejuger h pour dire de allons dire la
Perne parce que c'est nous c'est une
peine qu'on aura toute notre vie mais
dans dans la famille ça sera quelque
chose qui va nous rester à bah à vie
jusqu'à notre mort déjà je peux même pas
emmener ma
mère tous les ans sur la sur sa tombe
parce que maintenant je l'ai fait
revenir avec moi dans le Nord mais voilà
c'est je peux pas l'emmener parce que
bah financièrement ça coûte très cher de
déplacer de du Nord jusqu'au Sud et ça
c'est un manque terrible de pas aller
pouvoir se recueillir sur la tombe de sa
sœur parce que ben forcément on n'est
pas on n'est pas crisus entre guillemets
merci Frédéric en tout cas pour
témoignage très fort merci d'avoir été
là je sais que c'est important merci à
vous surtout merci à vous on se
retrouver dans un instant avec